أنا من محبي ريكو، لقد أخبرت الناس أن
المدعي العام الطموح لمقاطعة فولتون يستعد الليلة لاستخدام
أداة قانونية ضد الرئيس السابق
ترامب لم يواجهها قبل
اتهامات الابتزاز،
يقول خبراء قانونيون مضحكون في ويليس إنها يمكن أن تستدعي
قانون ريكو الخاص بجورج.  لملاحقة ترامب ورفاقه
فيما يتعلق بجهودهم
لإلغاء نتائج انتخابات 2020 في
جورجيا، تم تصميم قانون RICO في جورجيا
على غرار النسخة الفيدرالية التي تمثل ريكو التي تمثل
المنظمات المبتزة المتأثرة والفاسدة، وهو قانون تم توقيعه ليصبح قانونًا من قبل
ريتشارد نيكسون في عام 1970.
والقانون الفيدرالي في
معظم قوانين الولايات يعني بشكل أساسي أن لديك
مجموعة من الأفراد المنظمين الذين
يرتكبون سلسلة من الجرائم معًا
والمترابطة، وليس
عليك بالضرورة إثبات أن كل
فرد كان جزءًا من كل جريمة على حدة
ولكن هذا كان في الأساس  مصدر قلق
إجرامي مستمر،
تم استخدام قوانين ريكو بنجاح في
القضاء على شخصيات غوغاء معروفة مثل جون
جوتي، فات توني ساليرنو وغيره من قادة
أكبر خمس عائلات مافيا في نيويورك،
ويمكن محاكمة رؤساء الغوغاء وغيرهم في الجريمة المنظمة على جرائم
لم يرتكبوها.  ارتكبوها شخصيًا
لأنهم كانوا جزءًا من
منظمة إجرامية كانت
ترتكب جرائم بشكل منتظم، وقد تم
استخدام ريكو أيضًا لمحاكمة
أعضاء عصابة الدراجات النارية Hell's Angels،
وكانت فوني ويليس نفسها
من مؤيدي ريكو، وكانت
مبدعة للغاية و  لقد نجحت هي وفريقها في
استخدام هذا النظام الأساسي في
الماضي. وقد استخدم ويليس قوانين ريكو
للادعاء بأن مغني الراب الحائز على جائزة جرامي
يونغ ثوغ وعشرات من شركائه مع
علامته الموسيقية هم جزء من
عصابة إجرامية دفع بأنه غير مذنب ولم
يتم النظر في القضية.  "لم يتم تقديمها للمحاكمة بعد، ومنذ ما يقرب من
عقد من الزمن استخدمت ويليس ريكو في
قضية الفساد الكاسحة التي شملت
المدارس العامة في أتلانتا، وكانت هناك
إدانات تم الحصول عليها من خلال الإقرار بالذنب
ومحاكمة المعلمين
ومديري المدارس لتزييف
درجات الاختبارات الموحدة العام الماضي،
ودافعت ويليس عن استخدامها  السبب وراء
إعجابي بريكو هو أنني
أعتقد أن المحلفين أذكياء للغاية
ويريدون معرفة قصة الولاية بأكملها
ويريدون معرفة ما حدث، ريكو هي
أداة تسمح لمكتب المدعي العام
في مجال إنفاذ القانون برواية
القصة بأكملها  لكن أحد المحللين يحذر من المخاطر التي
قد يتحملها ويليس في رفع اتهامات ريكو
ضد ترامب، فمن الصعب
إثبات أنهم يعرفون
مفهومًا يصعب شرحه لهيئة المحلفين
ويطلبون منك إثبات أشياء إضافية
قد لا يتعين عليك إثباتها بطريقة أخرى.